[Musique]
quelle trace locaux vides les strates x
sur le long terme on s'avancerait un peu
trop en ayant une réponse formelle à
cette question si on commence à
apercevoir le bout du tunnel grâce à la
vaccination
il est évident que l'économie a pris un
sérieux coup dans les dents ni avril
persie a posé un chiffre sur cet état de
fait 4 124 milliards d'euros c'est ce
que coûterait cette crise à l'état
français sur trois ans entre 2020 et
un chiffre énorme et étonnamment précis
qui prend en compte les dépenses
s'engager comme le chômage partiel le
fonds de solidarité de coûts des mesures
sanitaires ou les impôts qui ne sont pas
rentrées dans les caisses
à cause de la récession de 2020 de 8,2
pour cent
la france n'est pas la seule dans ce cas
en europe sauf que d'autres pays se sont
retrouvés plongés dans la crise avec des
déficits de départ beaucoup moins
important avant le vide la france avait
déjà une dette de 100 % du pib
quand l'allemagne n'était qu'à 60% par
exemple on n'était pas tous sur la même
ligne de départ et on ne sera donc pas
tous égaux pour remonter la pente
on pourra se consoler un petit peu en se
disant qu'il y a pire que nous si on
traverse l'atlantique le déficit
budgétaire américain n'est pas mal non
plus 4500 milliards de dollars sur deux
ans 600 milliards rien qu'en mars
dernier des chiffres si gros qu'il
laisse forcément imaginé un impact
durable sur le monde et son économie